[Aplausos]
obtuvo el tercer lugar en las elecciones
del domingo y ahora los partidarios de
jean-luc mélenchon están siendo
cortejados por los principales
candidatos a la presidencia en francia
algo más fácil de decir que hacer robots
post mi voto debería ir a alguien en
quien realmente crea en este caso ni
macro ni marine lepén me han convencido
mélenchon dijo a sus partidarios que no
votaran por marine lepén pero no llegó a
respaldar a emanuel macrón sus
seguidores dicen que no están listos
para darle vía libre al actual
presidente
me dolería votar por él pero me dolería
más votar por la pena entonces si las
cosas son complejas de complex el ex
candidato se llevó a casa del 22% de los
votos del domingo y le fue bien entre
los votantes urbanos con educación
universitaria
así que nuestro máster hablamos mucho de
política no había mejor opción para la
juventud la sociedad el medio ambiente
las finanzas teníamos un programa que
era completo llamado juega lucchetti kg
mélenchon llegó un 1 por ciento por
detrás de marín le pen en la primera
ronda y sus partidarios dicen que están
decepcionados después de haber estado
tan cerca
son significa va a cambiar el sistema en
alguna parte y ahora mismo no vamos a
cambiar nada nos encontramos en la misma
situación que hace cinco años no te ves
votando por emanuel macro todavía no
estoy seguro y marie le pen con ella
tampoco se abstendrá
tal vez me vaya a pescar o emita un voto
en blancos
cuyo arribo equipo cuando faltan 11 días
para la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales una parte considerable de
los seguidores de mel en sión dicen que
es probable que voten en blanco o se
abstengan